et avec nous pourrons débattre ce soir
que le blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir club manche
maison merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés un petit peu plus loin on skype en
direct avec nous caroline galatée rose
géopolitologue présidente du film tant
que géo pragma bonsoir carolina galak
terence merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
première réaction vous qualifieriez de
quoi d'humiliation ce qui vient de se
passer pour notre pays
c'est à moi de me poser la question fait
bâillonner - nous regarder mais c'est
vrai que vous ne me voyez le pardon coup
il est activement grand ring à l'acte et
ans excusez moi non non je vous en fais
donc oui bien sûr c'est une humiliation
c'est surtout la dernière manifestation
est bien de respect dans quel on nous
tient c'est la manifestation d'un
déclassement stratégique parce que je
pense qu'il faut quand même on se
finisse par se poser les questions on ne
veut pas se poser des classements
stratégique et surtout c'est une claire
agression
contre notre autonomie industriels en
matière d'armement donc on a
effectivement beaucoup de fil à retordre
à cette décision qui était en plus enfin
tout a été fait tout a été en manche et
bien avant même les dernières les
derniers contacts entre le président
gbagbo et le président matheron dont on
est là dans un camouflet mais qui
correspond à j'allais dire à une
stratégie de deux longues de longue
haleine et de ça fait longtemps que
c'est que c'est le cas donc là on a
juste des signes des signes qu'il faut
interpréter dont il faut tirer certaines
conséquences et on va y venir évidemment
sur ses conséquences mais tout d'abord
sur le diagnostic caroline dialecte eros
moody agression camouflé pour la
première fois en tout quatre manches
maison la france a rappelé un centre son
ambassadeur aux états unis ça veut dire
quoi vous qui êtes ex-ambassadeur ça
chauffe c'est fois c'est le moins qu'on
puisse faire je voulais vous dire c'est
très grave évidemment ça n'est peut-être
pas tant que ça c'est surtout symbolique
tu réellement puisque les ambassades
continue de fonctionner le numéro 2
devient un chargé d'affaires
d'ailleurs les américains ont un chargé
d'affaires depuis que monsieur jobs
n'est plus président puisque le nouvel
ambassadeur n'a pas pris encore ses
fonctions mais évidemment sur le plan
symbolique c'est une mesure très lourde
et la france ne l'avait jamais fait il
avait des élus des états unis mais le
mac on l'a fait vis-à-vis de l'italie
quant à un ministre venait discuter avec
les gilets jaunes tous les samedis il a
fait aussi vis-à-vis de la turquie
lorsque monsieur erdogan avait tenu les
propos insultant vis-à-vis du président
de la république mais c'est rarissime
bon alors effectivement je pense que à
part cela il y aura sans doute d'autres
moyens envisagés parce que faire
pression sur les états unis et sur
l'australie le mal est fait faire
pression pour quoi faire puisque le mal
est fait d'ailleurs entre parenthèses
nous n'avons pas appelé notre ambassade
à vous notre ambassadrice au royaume uni
je pense que monsieur boris johnson et
vexée que l'on se le tiennent pour
quantité négligeable finalement on n'a
même pas jugé utile de prendre la
moindre mesure à son égard or c'est lui
qui a été la cheville ouvrière vous
croyez justement on le prend pour une
quantité négligeable sans doute il ya
beaucoup de différents sur l'application
du bric site puisqu'il s'applique
toujours pas l' annexe irlande du nord
pas de contrôle sur les produits qui
rentrent en irlande du nord et puis par
ailleurs nos pêcheurs ne peuvent
toujours pas aller à jersey refah ya
beaucoup de sujets de différends et
qu'ils nous accusent de lâcher les
migrants sur les côtes britanniques donc
peut-être qu'il fallait pas non plus
ajouté d'autres d'autres difficultés
mais effectivement il faut envisager
sans doute d'autres mesures et en
fonction de l'analyse qu'on a de la
réalité de ce qui vient de se passer il
ya naturellement la faire des sous
marins qui est une affaire très grave
mais aussi le fait que la vérité vient
d'éclater c'est à dire pour les
américains l'inde au pacifique la
fameuse stratégie indo pacifique dont
tous les sites en discute depuis quatre
ou cinq ans et bien pour monsieur byden
c'est une alliance militaire dirigée par
les états unis pour que les membres
achètent uniquement du matériel
militaire américain et qui est dirigé
contre la chine bon au moins six à
partir de ça la france peut se
déterminer parce que y'a d'autres pays
de la région qui ne sont pas d'accord
l'un ne va pas rentrer dans cette
alliance le japon et la corée du sud ont
des alliances direct avec les états unis
mais qui porte sur d'autres d'autres
causes d'autres considérations la
nouvelle zélande ne veux pas entrer dans
cet accord parce qu'elle n'accepte pas
dans ces ports les navires à propulsion
nucléaire
par conséquent il est possible que ces
noyaux belliqueux
reste finalement tout seul en tout cas
pour jean yves le drian c'est clairement
une rupture de confiance majeure avec
washington pour la classe politique
française on disait c'est un échec une
humiliation mondial donc qu'il faut
tirer les conséquences
regardez tout d'abord cette réaction
celle du patron de la région des hautes
france candidat à la présidentiel xavier
bertrand
la question de savoir si pour les
américains nous comptons aussi ou si
nous sommes en deuxième division si la
réponse ne nous satisfait pas ce soit
que mettre sur la table la question de
la participation de la france au
commandement intégré de l'otan il ya
deux idées en danse que véhicule de
xavier bertrand justement la france qui
ne compte pas vraiment au sud est des
états unis et bien sûr la sortie de
l'otan va commencer par les prendre dans
l'ordre clairement caroline gaillac
terros la france quantité négligeable
pour les états unis il ya plus des
doublages crois que c'est clair je me
demande d'ailleurs comment on peut avoir
des doutes depuis déjà des années c'est
cette saynète c'est clair et on voit
bien qu'il ya une continuité dans la
politique extérieure américaine qui va
bien au delà des républicains ou
démocrates
il faut pas oublier que le néo
conservatisme est né du côté démocrate
de l'échiquier politique américain donc
là nous sommes dans un contexte en fait
de repos la risation agressive et
d'instrumentalisation reprise en main
prêts nets de l'otan à cette fin repos
l'organisation bien sûr contre la chine
et il faut mettre en ordre de marche et
les vassaux donc à des vassaux de
premier rang là bas c'est net c'est
laisser les fanboys bon dont on a assez
parlé c'est un vieux pacte et qui est
toujours très opérateurs opérationnel et
puis il y a bien sûr alors les
australiens mais ils vont faire une
mauvaise affaire je pense que c'est
aussi très intéressant de regarder ce
qu'ils vont gagner alors à leur
soumission parce que finalement ils vont
avoir en acceptant le le marché
américain les dates chantage sur le n
vous êtes avec nous est contre nous si
vous êtes contre nous attentions vous
fait certes la majeure partie de notre
commerce avec la chine met donc on
essaie de les faire basculer pour qu'ils
ne se tournent plus du tout vers la
chine donc là il ya eu ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que ce contrat du
siècle qui date de 2016 dès sa
conclusion déjà dès l'appel d'offres
légales beaucoup de lobbying anti
français notamment qu'à part des
allemands qui sont qui tiennent toujours
la corde vient certaine façon est plus
que jamais d'ailleurs en europe mais
contre nous ce qui est assez regrettable
mais enfin et il ya eu surtout un
lobbying intense contre ce contrat donc
aujourd'hui je dirais et comme comme la
ti l'ambassadeur blanche façon c'est
trop tard la messe est dite donc il faut
que nous nous prenions des mesures pour
montrer on ne nous marche pas dessus
impunément que nous aussi nous sommes
une puissance du pacifique que nous
avons des intérêts à défendre mais nous
ne sommes pas dans une position
belliqueuse
rigide que ce soit vis-à-vis de la chine
contre la chine on vous derrière contre
la russie ce qui est la nouvelle posture
de l'otan donc c'est ça le contexte
c'est c'est ça c'est ça qui est
important et nous devons nous décider
quelles sont nos intérêts ça ne veut pas
dire quitter les états unis qu'on allait
vers la chine ça veut dire partir de
nous
refourguer une diplomatie et une
politique étrangère qui soit autre chose
que du tueur atlantis est juste à
attendre n'est ce pas qu'on nous
considère quand nous recevons des
preuves toujours plus nombreuses que ce
n'est pas le cas on cherche surtout à
enterrer bien sûr tous les rêves
complètement utopique et naïf de
d'autonomie stratégiques européennes
mais on sert mon cherche surtout à
montrer à la france elle a intérêt elle
aussi à rentrer dans le rang et vite 6
et bien elle leur fera les frais je ne
pense pas qu'on puisse laisser faire
cela que d'enjeux maison justement
riggio bagdad on l'a vu faire du vélo
dans le lower ce week-end pas d'ailleurs
un titre de presse aux etats-unis alors
que nous on parle que de ça
un certain chanteur aznavour disait il
faut savoir quitter la table quand
l'amour est desservie quelle est la
stratégie d'une france qui aujourd'hui
boudé
par son ancien allié d'hier et
américains qu'il est toujours m'enfin
c'est vrai que c'est de plus en plus
discutable quand on voit les derniers
développements de l'actualité
sur le temps je note que personne ne
propose que la france quitte l'alliance
atlantique par conséquent ce qui est
proposé par certains candidats à
l'élection présidentielle aujourd'hui
c'est de quitter les organes militaires
intégrés
c'est à dire d'en revenir à ce qu'elle
ait fait le général de gaulle à l'époque
où il avait décidé du retrait de la
france les organes militaires intégrés
mais à l'époque ça aller beaucoup plus
loin puisqu'il y avait beaucoup de bases
américaines en france donc elle devait
partir il y avait le siège de l'otan en
france à la porte dauphine et a dû
partir et c'était évidemment à un coup
de tonnerre personne ne pensait que la
france était capable de faire cela et
aujourd'hui
effectivement on peut se demander si
dans le fond emmanuel macron qui ne
déteste pas les prises de position un
peu transgressif qui a dix qui a déclaré
la mort cérébrale de l'otan dans le fond
pourrait être tenté par cette décision
mais il aurait tout contre lui
l'ensemble de l'establishement militaire
et l'establishment militaire ne veut pas
quitter l'otan parce que d'ailleurs un
certain nombre de nos opérations en
afrique dépendent de l'infrastructure de
l'otan notamment en matière logistique
en matière de renseignement donc le
sujet va être discutée et en effet ceux
ci doit aussi être évoquée entre mâcon
et le président joe biden puisqu'ils
vont se parler probablement demain et
que en tout cas macron fera un discours
en vidéoconférence al'onu demain dans ce
discours il va probablement dire il va
lancer un appel à la paix et à dire que
nous ne sommes pas là pour monter des
alliances contre la chine ou contre
quiconque d'ailleurs mais probablement
que joe biden va dire que ce qu'il a
fait avec l'australie c'est pour le
maintien de la paix et c'est pas du tout
agressif vis-à-vis de la chine parce que
c'est comme ça que les américains
présentent leurs affaires
clément caroline galak terros intérêts
ou non pour la france de quitter l'otan
parce que oui des candidats à la
présidentielle le demandent ils sont un
certain nombre aujourd'hui
de tous les bars si j'ose dire d'extrême
droite à l'extrême gauche en passant par
la droite au centre
non il s'agit pas pour moi il ne s'agit
pas de quitter l'otan ne serait ce que
pour savoir encore ce qui se passe en
revanche les organes militaires intégrés
oui certainement non seulement au plan
symbolique mais aussi parce que c'est
aussi par ces mécanismes là que la
france est entraîné dans une posture
collective de bellicisme hanté chinois
qui ne correspond pas du tout notre
vision du monde qui roulait 7,7 les
américains veulent de nouveaux reculs
avisé le monde en deux en deux temps
avec nous pour nous les bons les
méchants les blanc et noirs ça suffit
c'est plus comme ça du tout on est dans
un monde police entré avec de grands
ensembles régionaux avec des puissances
importante danser ensemble et nous la
france nous avons à aa à pouvoir faire
entendre notre voix qui est une voie d'
équilibre qui n'est pas du tout une voix
de 2,2 bellick aux hits et donc à
laquelle pour laquelle nous n'avons
aucun intérêt
aucun intérêt oui aucun intérêt pour
vous aussi non dans la maison rien n'a
pu mais il faut qu'il faut juste arrêter
d'obéir et arrêter de subir les
patrouilles ont suivi à 20 euros oui je
pense que en effet il arrive qu'on on se
range dans le courant dans le mainstream
comme on dit a le temps et qu'on peut
toujours dire non à l'otan puisque les
décisions sont prises par consensus si
quelqu'un a le courage de dire non et de
dire non aux états unis et bien la
décision n'est pas prise peut-être
faut-il le faire de temps à autre mais
ce que je voulais dire c'est que dans
les circonstances actuelles ce qu'il
faut surtout faire c'est reconstruire
une doctrine française de l'inde au
pacifique ils soient pas la doctrine
américaine et la doctrine française de
l'inde au pacifique qui ressemble un
petit peu à celle de l'inde à celle des
pays comme singapour comme la malaisie
comme des pays avec lesquels nous avons
des accords de coopération stratégique
même comme le vietnam c'est d'avoir en
effet un ensemble d'accords avec des
coopérations sur mesure dans chaque cas
mais pas une alliance militaire et je
pense que c'est ce qui va être si je
dois être démontrée dans les prochains
mois il est possible de monter quelque
chose de ce genre peut-être est-ce mais
là aussi on peut il faut pas désespérer
de l'ordre n'est ce pas l'europe a
publié sa propre vision de l'inde au
pacifique manque de chance c'était le
jour où monsieur byden parlait alors
effectivement personne n'a entendu ce
que disait madame van der leyen est ce
que vivait le président du conseil
européen c'était probablement très
modérée enfin on l'a on a tous lu mais
c'était effectivement quelque chose qui
ressemblait un peu à la conception
française de l'inde au pacifique sans
naturellement le volet militaire puisque
l'union européenne n'a pas de volet
militaire et que le volet militaire il
est national et pour nous nous vendons
des rafales nous vendrons des sous
marins à l'inde
nous pourrions vendre davantage nous
avons vendu 36 rafale qui ont été livrés
cette année à l'inde c'est très
important nous construisons six
sous-marins scorpène actuellement en a
trois sont en service peut-être
pourrait-on et les indiens le soin des
trains l'australien elle annonce un gros
contrat aujourd'hui paradoxalement
absolument et peut-être pourrait-on
aussi que ray ou sceller une coopération
militaire qui ne dit pas vraiment son
nom avec le vietnam parce que les tam on
forme des gens aux opérations de
maintien de la paix de l'onu on forme
des médecins militaires on n'a pas plus
loin parce qu'on a peur peut tous fils à
l'acide il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui la
mer de chine là là le conflit en mer de
chine du sud était précisément un
conflit entre la chine et le vietnam car
oui euh caractère aux ouvriers réagir
aux propos de deux clubs dans sa maison
non mais c'est à dire nos trains c'est
merveilleux mais ces 300 millions donc
cesser c'est formidable c'est une c'est
une petite niet et nous avons pris
l'habitude de ramasser les miettes et de
nous en contenter donc il est pour moi
pour moi si vous voulez il est il est
clair que maintenant il faut il faut
complètement changé de portage d'un
poids le français du point de vue de la
politique étrangère française il doit
être fondée sur de toutes autres bases
ensuite quand l'ambassadeur planches
maison dit qu'effectivement l'europe n'a
pas de bol et militaires oui sauf que
nous avons un président qui nous
explique qu'il va y aura une autonomie
stratégique européenne ce qui est une
pure utopie dans le traité de lisbonne
il est clair il est dit clairement et
simplement que c'est le temps le volet
militaire de l'europe donc là on est
dans une reprise en main que nous avons
à mon avis nous français absolument
aucun intérêt aucune raison de subir de
reprise en main militaire
du tout comment dirais-je très très
brutale qui veut réimposer de nouveau
une vision complètement antagoniste du
monde avec un leader du monde dit je ne
sais quoi libre peut-être
vis-à-vis d'autres pays qui en rêvent
d'autres intérêts et aujourd'hui c'est
la chine voilà je pense simplement que
il faut pas oublier vraiment que les les
australiens là ont été soumis eux aussi
un chantage pour prendre cette décision
ça va leur coûter plus cher ça va être
plus longs ils auront moins de sous
marins ça va être très compliqué ils
vont être complètement soumis à une
dépendance technologique et en matière
nucléaire vis-à-vis des etats-unis donc
on est dans ce renversement et nous
avons franchement quelle quelle est
notre intérêt à nous qui avons des
possessions en indo pacifique qui avant
une capacité politique propre en indo
pacifique et des intérêts à défendre
mais nous ne sommes absolument pas
opposé aux chinois pacific dont je ne
vois pas pourquoi l'otan qui est en
train d'étendre son spectre parce que
l'otan n'est plus seulement une
organisation militaire elle est de plus
en plus d'une organisation à spectre
politique globale ça va jusqu'à
l'afrique naturellement mais ça va de
plus en plus maintenant en indo
pacifique ce n'est pas notre intérêt de
participer à ce type d'opération y
seront qui seront montées comme des
opérations de pure coercition de pure
pression et de pur chantage la france
est une puissance d'équilibré de
médiation merci en tout cas tous les
deux caroline leguellec terros d'avoir
été avec mon claude branche maison sur
ce plateau et l'annulation